thousands still without power in the
wake of storm arwin are now bracing for
storm barrow
snowfall overnight has already been a
massive setback for this area of
northumberland
john bell's power had finally been
reconnected after six days
only for it to be cut off again
he called it a heart-in-mouth moment
we lost the power and it we thought oh
it's just a glitch and it was only going
to be a matter of seconds and then when
it would start to drag on a bit we would
it then becomes
or how long how long has it gone and you
get quite cross about it because you
think well hang on these guys have
worked really hard to get the power
restored uh we've had a local councillor
who's pushed things dramatically and
done an absolutely sterling job
why this wasn't an emergency
with the army involved far sooner than
what it is now
snowfall has made an already desperate
situation far worse here
the army is now deployed to check on the
vulnerable on a ninth day without power
for homes in the northeast
and business secretary quasi quatten has
met with northern power grid to survey
the storm damage
99.5 of people have are back on now for
the 4 000 i think it's completely
unacceptable that they're still off uh
power and that's why i have uh
instituted a review into whether the
companies have invested enough off-gem
are looking at this and of course we can
uh there will be some sort of
enforcement
uh
measures to make sure that the companies
are held to account that's very
important but a review doesn't help
people now in homes with no heating no
hot water no electricity
a local councillor for rothbury says his
calls for generators have gone
unanswered from a local level i would i
would absolutely agree for the fire and
rescue service the county council the
mountain rescue uh northumbria police
has been absolutely fantastic but in my
view a major incident should have been
called earlier on in the week and i
think that came down to more politics
than actual practicalities
this rural area is used to snow but with
so many people well into their second
week with no power there's a real sense
of isolation and neglect here many angry
at just how long it's taken westminster
to respond to this crisis
many are now fearful of a winter with
intermittent power a crisis that could
become critical as they brace here for
more snow
and storm barrow
sally lockwood sky news northumberland